MRS.
OBAMA: Thanks for being here.
You guys, as I always say, rest yourselves.
You got a lot of work to do.
(Laughter.)
Well, welcome to the White House.
It is truly a pleasure to be here with all
of you today for the first ever White House
Convening on Food Marketing to Children.
But before we get started, I just wanted to
take a moment to express my sincere heartbreak
over Monday's tragedy at the Navy Yard here
in Washington.
The men and women who lost their lives devoted
their careers to protecting our country.
And as we mourn those that we lost and we
pray for those who were injured, we also honor
their service, and we hold all of their loved
ones in our hearts at this very difficult
time.
So with that, we're going to put you to work.
Thank you again for being here.
I want to start by thanking Sam for that very
kind introduction, but more importantly for
all the work that he and his team have done
to make Let's Move a reality.
And I want to thank all of you for joining
us today.
All of you in this room, you come to this
issue from all different angles.
You're experts, advocates, parents.
You represent food and beverage companies,
media and entertainment companies, and so
much more.
And we're eager to have a lively and constructive
dialogue with you about how we market food
to our children.
We're eager to hear more from everyone in
this room about what's working, where we're
falling short, and how we can keep moving
forward together on this complex and challenging
but very important issue.
And I think it's important to note that we're
having this conversation in the midst of what
I believe is a cultural shift that is happening
in this country -- a transformation in how
we live and eat that many of us could never
have imagined even just a few years ago.
I see it everywhere I go all across this country.
I see it in chain restaurants that are serving
kale salads, and they're filling kids' menus
with not just nuggets and fries, but with
broccoli and whole-wheat pasta.
I see it in churches where instead of fried
chicken and mac and cheese for church supper,
they're serving up grilled fish and brown
rice.
I see it online where parenting, cooking,
and health blogs are crammed with healthy
recipes and tips about providing better nutrition
for our kids.
And I see it in schools where students can't
wait to tell me about their new salad bar
or how they ate a radish or tried cauliflower
for the first time, and actually like it.
In fact, we recently sponsored a recipe contest
for kids here at the White House, and we got
over 1,300 entries from 50 states across the
country, and I can't tell you how many of
those recipes featured quinoa.
(Laughter.)
Go figure.
And if all of this doesn't provide sufficient
evidence of an important shift, then just
take a look at the market research.
The National Restaurant Association surveyed
chefs about trends in their industry, and
three of the top 10 trends were specifically
about healthy kids' meals.
A survey by the Food Marketing Institute found
that 90 percent of grocery stores are offering
healthy recipes to their customers, and 98
percent of them maintain health and wellness
websites.
And today, for the first time in decades,
we're actually starting to move the needle
on this issue.
Between 2008 and 2011, obesity rates among
low-income preschoolers dropped in 19 states
and territories across the country.
And childhood obesity rates are falling in
cities like New York and Philadelphia, and
in states like California and Mississippi.
But while we have made important progress,
when one in three kids is still on track to
develop diabetes, and when diet has now surpassed
smoking as the number one risk factor for
disease and death in this country, then we
clearly have much more work to do.
And, yes, we have made meaningful changes
in a number of areas by getting healthier
food into our schools and communities, but
at the end of the day, if we truly want to
solve this problem, we also need to get our
kids to actually want to eat these healthier
options.
And I say this not just as a First Lady who's
been working on this issue for the past three
and a half years; I say this as a mom who
has been working hard to raise two girls.
As you know, I haven't always lived in the
White House.
(Laughter.)
Not so long ago, I was a busy working mom
desperate to find quick, affordable meals
and snacks for my family.
I needed cereal that my girls could pour themselves.
I needed lunches I could pack in a hurry.
I needed juice boxes that my three-year-old
could hold in her hand in the backseat of
my car.
I needed dinners that came pre-cooked and
ready to pop in the microwave.
And most importantly, I needed my kids to
actually eat all of this food I was buying
for them.
And all of you in the food and beverage industry
delivered for me.
You manufactured and sold the convenience
foods I needed, and you did a brilliant job
making those foods something my kids would
want.
So when I opened those boxes and bags, my
girls were happy, and I was happy -- problem
solved.
But then, like a lot of moms, I started learning
more about nutrition and health.
I started reading labels.
I started getting warnings from my pediatrician
about the health of my
Kids.
And I began to realize that some of these
foods that were so quick and cheap and tasty
weren't always healthy for my kids.
So once again, moms like me turned to your
industry for help.
But this time, we didn't just want the foods
to be convenient and affordable -- we wanted
them to be good for our kids as well.
And once again, many of you have started to
deliver by manufacturing some of the healthier
options.
And that is an important first step.
But once again, moms like me are relying on
all of you to actually help our kids get excited
about eating that food.
And that's why I wanted to bring all of you
together today -- because you guys know better
than anyone how to get kids excited.
You've done it before, and we need you to
do it again.
And fortunately you have everything it takes
to get this done because through the magic
of marketing and advertising, all of you,
more than anyone else, have the power to shape
our kids' tastes and desires.
You all know that our kids are like little
sponges --- they absorb whatever is around
them.
But they don't yet have the ability to question
and analyze what they're told.
Instead, they believe just about everything
they see and hear, especially if it's on TV.
And when the average child is now spending
nearly eight hours a day in front of some
kind of screen, many of their opinions and
preferences are being shaped by the marketing
campaigns you all create.
And that's where the problem comes in.
You see, the average child watches thousands
of food advertisements each year, and 86 percent
of these ads are for products loaded with
sugar, fat, salt.
By contrast, our kids see an average of just
one ad a week for healthy products like water
to fruits and vegetables.
Just one ad a week.
And as you all know, these ads work.
Kids who see foods advertised on TV are significantly
more likely to ask for them at the store --- a
phenomenon known as "pester power."
(Laughter.)
New to me.
Sounds right though.
And research shows that a child's first request
for a product happens as early as 24 months,
and 75 percent of the time, this request takes
place in a grocery store.
And given what our kids are seeing on TV,
it should come as no surprise what they're
asking for.
One study revealed that 45 percent of kids'
food requests were things like cookies and
candy, burgers and fries, and chips, but just
3 percent were for fruits and vegetables.
So from the time our kids are still in diapers,
we as parents are already fighting an uphill
battle to
get them interested in the foods that will
actually nourish them and help them grow.
Now, like many parents, Barack and I do our
best to limit our daughters' TV time.
But as you all know, these ads aren't just
on TV.
They're on the internet, in video games, smart
phones, billboards.
They're in schools and store displays.
They're everywhere, and parents just can't
keep up, no matter how hard we try.
So whatever we all might believe about personal
responsibility and self-determination, I think
we
can agree that it doesn't necessarily apply
to children.
I think that we can all agree that parents
deserve more control over the products and
messages their kids are exposed to.
And that's why I was so pleased that 17 major
American companies came together on their
own as part of the Children's Food and Beverage
Advertising Initiative to adopt new standards
for marketing to kids.
And I know this wasn't easy.
Forging consensus among fierce competitors
is a challenge to say the least.
But these new standards are beginning to have
an impact, and I commend all of these companies
for taking action.
But of course, while limiting the marketing
of unhealthy food is critical, it's not enough.
We also need companies to actually market
healthy foods to kids --- foods that have
real
nutritional value, foods that are fortified
with real fruits and vegetables, whole grains
and low-fat dairy.
Now, I say this mindful that companies exist
to make a profit, and they need that in order
to survive.
And those profits keep our economy going every
day.
But the fact is that marketing nutritious
foods to our kids isn't just good for our
kids' health -- it can also be good for companies'
bottom lines.
For example, the folks at Birds Eye Vegetables
launched a major marketing campaign featuring
characters from the popular kids' show "iCarly."
And their sales jumped 20 percent in just
two months.
Vidalia Onion did a campaign with "Shrek"
-- one of my favorites -- and their sales
went up 50 percent.
So I'm confident that you all can sell healthy
foods to our kids and remain competitive and
profitable.
That's why some of your companies' marketers
are playing a key role in a new campaign to
inspire people in this country to drink more
water.
You see, we know that water is such an important
component to good health, but so many other
beverages have millions of marketing dollars
behind them that water often gets drowned
out.
That's why last week, we launched the new
Drink Up campaign -- a campaign to bring attention
to water as a healthy choice so that when
people are thirsty, they reach for a glass
of water.
So I say this because when it comes to believing
in the power of marketing to promote healthy
choices to our kids, I'm not just talking
the talk, I'm actually walking the walk on
this one.
But so far, I've spent a lot of time talking
about food and beverage companies.
But those of you from media companies also
play a critical role in marketing food to
our children, and I want to call on all of
you to do your part as well.
That means, for example, limiting the use
of your licensed characters to market unhealthy
food to kids, and limiting unhealthy food
ads in your programming.
Disney has pledged to do just that, and I
know that other media companies can follow
suit.
But I'm also asking you to actually use your
licensed characters to promote healthy food.
"Sesame Street" has been doing this for years,
which is why, when parents turn on "Sesame
Street" or the Disney Channel, they know and
trust that their kids won't be bombarded with
messages promoting unhealthy food.
And that trust is valuable.
That trust is good for your businesses.
That's why so many of you in the private sector
are leading the way on this issue.
You are innovating.
You're taking risks.
You're serving as models for your industries,
and it's starting to make a difference -- not
just for our kids, but for your shareholders
as well.
And I'm here today with one simple request
-- and that is to do even more and move even
faster to market responsibly to our kids.
Now, I want to be clear about what I'm asking
here.
I am not asking anyone to take the fun out
of childhood.
As we all know, treats are one of the best
parts of being a kid.
Instead, the goal here is to empower parents
instead of undermining them as they try to
make healthier choices for their families.
And we need you to lead the way in creating
demand for healthy foods so that kids actually
start "pestering" us for those foods in the
grocery store.
And then parents actually start buying them,
and then companies have incentives to make
and sell even more of those foods.
And ideally, in a decade or so, we would see
a dramatic shift across the entire industry.
We'd see companies shifting marketing dollars
away from those less healthy products and
investing those dollars in your healthier
products instead.
That's how we can make healthy eating a way
of life for our kids and for our families.
And make no mistake about it, meeting these
goals isn't just the right decision for the
short or medium term; it can affect your businesses
for decades to come.
See, the decisions that you make about marketing
won't just affect what our kids are eating
today -- those decisions are going to also
affect the health of your workforce tomorrow.
Businesses are losing $37 [$73] billion a
year due to absenteeism, lost productivity,
and health care costs associated with obesity-related
conditions.
And just imagine what that number will look
like in twenty years from now if we stand
by and let today's unhealthy kids grow into
unhealthy adults who become the employees
of tomorrow.
And there's another long-term factor that's
also worth considering, and that is the potential
trend in our kids' food preferences and taste.
You see, over the past few years, we've seen
some real changes in the foods our kids are
eating,
starting from the time they're born.
For example, changes in the Women, Infants
and Children Program are helping millions
of women across America buy healthier products
for their kids.
And 10,000 childcare centers across the country
have committed to serving more nutritious
food as part of Let's Move Childcare.
In addition, we have implemented sweeping
changes in America's school lunch program,
such that nearly 32 million children across
the country are now eating more fruits, and
vegetables, whole grains, and other healthy
foods every day.
And starting next year, school vending machines
will be stocked with healthy items as well.
So healthier eating is starting to become
the new norm for our kids.
This is what they're getting used to, and
for many, this is all they'll ever know.
And as their palates and their habits adjust,
that could have a serious effect on their
taste and preferences not just as children,
but for the rest of their lives.
It could even affect what they ultimately
buy and serve their own children in the future.
So this isn't just some passing trend or fad.
So there might be those out there whose strategy
is to just wait this out -- folks who might
still be thinking to themselves, well, in
a few years, this lady will be gone -- (laughter)
-- and this whole Let's Move thing will finally
be over, so we can go back to business as
usual.
And I know that none of you here are thinking
that way.
(Laughter.)
But if you know anyone who is -- (laughter)
-- you might want to remind them that I didn't
create this issue, and it's not going to go
away three and a half years from now when
I'm no longer First Lady.
This issue has truly taken on a life of its
own because it is affecting just about every
family and every community in this country.
Parents are increasingly anxious as they see
their kids developing diabetes, high cholesterol,
high blood pressure -- conditions that would
have been unthinkable to find in children
just a generation ago.
There are now 79 million pre-diabetics in
this county, many of them young adults, and
we're
even seeing people in their twenties and thirties
having heart attacks and strokes.
So I have yet to meet a single parent who
doesn't understand the threat of obesity to
their health and to their children's health.
And they are looking for solutions.
They're starting to think about how they feed
themselves and their families.
And you all can take advantage of this.
You can get ahead of the curve.
You have everything it takes right now to
seize this societal challenge as an unprecedented
business opportunity.
Right now, your companies employ some of the
most brilliant, creative, innovative minds
in the entire country.
And you all can sell just about anything to
our kids.
And if anyone can get our kids to eat their
vegetables, it's all of you.
And I know it won't be easy.
I know you might have to take some short-term
risks to get a long-term payoff.
But that's what great American companies do
-- they act boldly, they innovate, they take
risks.
And remember, it wasn't that long ago that
"going green" or taking your business online
were considered risky endeavors.
But throughout our history, the companies
that saw where the future was headed and took
that leap have been rewarded.
And I want you to know that I will do everything
in my power to celebrate and highlight this
kind of leadership on behalf of our kids.
That's what I've been doing since I first
started working on this issue, whether it
was visiting a
Walmart stocked with fresh produce, or having
dinner at an Olive Garden with a healthier
kids menu, or hanging out with Mickey to celebrate
Disney's achievements on this issue.
And I am eager to have these kinds of celebrations
with every company in this room.
So I hope that all of you will really engage.
I hope that you'll really talk to each other,
and learn from each other, and come up with
new solutions that will make a real difference
for our kids.
We want to hear from everyone involved in
this issue -- from industry leaders to advocates
to researchers and to parents -- because we're
all in this together.
And while I know I've been talking a lot about
corporate America's responsibilities on this
issue, the advocates and experts here today
have an important responsibility too.
Your words matter.
You all can help either provide incentives
to change, or you can be barriers to change.
So we need you to be constructive in your
criticisms and strategic in your calls to
action, because when it comes to marketing,
it can be hard for companies to take risks.
They face pressures from Wall Street.
There are also limits to how fast they can
move and how far they can go before they start
losing customers.
So when companies do step up and take risks,
we need to be supportive, even if we think
they haven't gone far enough.
We need to help them make those risks pay
off, so that they'll go even farther, and
so that other companies will follow their
lead.
And as for those of you in the private sector,
I hope that you will head back to your companies
ready to think big and act boldly on behalf
of our kids because while running a profitable
business is important, I know that you all
aren't just business executives.
You all are also good neighbors, and good
citizens, and proud parents and grandparents.
Many of you didn't go into business just to
make money, but to problem solve and make
people's lives better.
You went into business to create great American
products and build great American institutions,
and to leave a legacy that your kids and grandkids
will inherit with pride.
And in the end, that's what Let's Move is
all about.
It's about the legacy we're leaving for the
next generation and generations to come.
And standing here today with all of you, people
who represent some of the most visionary,
pioneering companies and organizations in
this country, I have never felt more confident
about our children's future and, of course,
the future of this country.
So I look forward to hearing about what you
all come up with today, and I look forward
to celebrating new commitments and achievements
in the months and years ahead.
Thank you all.
God bless you.
Good luck and work hard.
(Applause.)